hi i'm anthony fisher for recent TV and
i'm here with - al-mansour the director
of the new film wadjda thanks so much
for joining us well thank you so much
for having me
watched is the story of a young Saudi
girl with an independent even rebellious
streak and her quest to buy a bike it's
the first feature film shot entirely in
Saudi Arabia and by extension the first
Saudi film directed by a woman so
congratulations on that thank you so
much
and this is your first foray into
filmmaking yes that's pretty incredible
that is my first feature but I don't
like a documentary in a few shorts I had
read that you had to direct some scenes
of Iowa eat okey this is kind of like
art as cloak and dagger the country is
segregated and when we are over we are
outside I wasn't able to be with the
crew because it is not expected and and
the country is very conservative and
nearly we don't want to create the scene
it's a small budget we don't want to
delayed all that they had a monitor for
me and a walkie-talkie and I used that
walkie took it to the maximum ice cream
that there were I just shouted make the
frame wider
it to be very clear to our audience I
may not be aware movies are banned there
is no there are no movie theaters in
Saudi Arabia so how does one become a
lover of the art form of film in Saudi
Arabia it exists a lot in Saudi on via
DVD and VHS but yeah you can watch film
in privacy at home but you cannot watch
them like can you talk a little bit
about
wajda's little rebellions and what they
represent I wanted to to depict a
character that will never give up a
character that is willing to embrace
life and fight for it and not in a way
I'd like to be radical 3 against or
anything but just to have a dream and
pursue it and I think such messages are
very important in the Middle East
because to have a change you really need
to change your heart and make yourself
happier in everyday life and also it
needs a lot of work and a lot of
resistance and a lot of people think if
they change the regime and their life
will be all ok all of a sudden doesn't
happen them and there is a lot of a
disappointment because change needs a
lot of dedication and a lot of work
wadjda subverts the oppressive system
that she's living under and saves money
for her by
through trade and entrepreneurialship do
you see free trade is a liberating force
I think it's yeah it's very important to
find solution to things and to find your
own voice and because there's so many
obstacles in everyday life and
especially for women they learn how to
maneuver it they know how to work around
it I also wanted to tell an emotional
story a story that is engaging I grew up
watching a lot of Hollywood films and I
knew how much power is there to be to
bring a story that is uplifting and that
touches people and rather changes so
much and how people think and how people
see the world does any hope exist for
the rights for Saudi women or do they
have to do what you did and leave oh no
I didn't leave I go back to my hometown
all the time it is very hard place for
women because it is conservative and
tribal excluding women from the public
life and but I think there is hope and
by saying that it's not like by going
outside and demonstrating because this
is easy it is easy to go outside and
spend the night shouting and then you go
home it says but it's difficult to start
making things and a real desire to
embrace love and becoming more tolerant
and appreciating art and things like
this doesn't don't come over night it
needs time to grow I mean the film is
very slice of life and while the teacher
and the father kind of take on
villainous roles it almost seems like
the antagonist is Saudis society itself
warding this lovely the Smart Girls
attempts to explore and express herself
where among the the male society in
Saudi Arabia is the change going to come
from Abdullah the guy she loves she she
has a crush on ha ha so that is I think
from the younger generation from would
dine her friend because they are growing
up in a different world where they have
access to so many things that I when I
was a kid didn't have they have internet
and though I remember when we addition
to her and she doesn't speak any English
I asked her to sing because there is a
reciting part and she started singing
for Justin Bieber perfectly but she
doesn't speak English and and they have
access to pop culture and they know how
the world is and I think they want to to
fall in love and be and and move away
from being so much conservative and so
on that culture that sometimes is
denies them a lot of things that makes
them happy there's a scene where wadjda
and Abdullah are walking past the
suicide bombers funeral and he talks
about the Bombers reward of 72 virgins
and watched it playfully imagines
blowing herself up and getting herself a
new bike there's a universal innocence
here to some real harsh realities what
kind of feedback have you gotten from
that scene mixed I think I haven't get
any direct ones but I feel people fear
awkward it's supposed to be funny and
people don't laugh they don't know if
they should laugh or she doesn't again I
just wanted to bring life and have
people discover things for themselves I
wasn't trying to be judgmental or trying
to say things and direct people towards
something in particular but I see
sometimes interesting stuff happening
and the society around me I feel it is
interesting that incidents is very
interesting and says something a lot
projects more about the culture and and
all that so I put it in the film and
hoping people will find the same thing
well thanks so much for talking with us
hi file Mansoor the director of the new
film watch dev for a reason TV I'm
Anthony Fisher